Continental Tire coaches corner is NBC
football night America's Tony Dungy good
morning Tony how are you today they did
pretty good to talk to you I'm doing
great a little warm down here in Florida
but doing fine okay
you're watching last night you got Tampa
against Jacksonville and you got a
quarterback who you thought was your
future and maybe you realize he's not
your future what do you do in a
situation like that if you're the
Jaguars with Blake bortles well you have
to make a decision you have to say we're
going to take this year and really find
out or we're going to just open it up do
what's best and try to win this mini
game we can and if that means we've got
to make a change we do it it is that's a
tough tough call when you've got a
quarterback you draft that you want it
to work you just feel like we've got to
make this work we got to give him the
opportunity and I think that's where
they are right now I think I'll save
with him but it didn't look great last
night and when you have a quarterback
lose confidence I don't know if you had
a situation like that you were obviously
lucky to have Peyton Manning but how do
you get a quarterbacks confidence back
well you know when I came down here in
96 to the books they had drafted Trent
Dilfer I think he was in his third year
or going into the third year and we just
basically said you're going to be the
quarterback for this for the next two
years don't worry about it we're going
to build this get some players around
you and you just got to go out there and
relax and play and he went through some
ups and downs especially my first year
especially early on but we stayed with
it he got through that and developed and
sometimes you have to do that you just
have to say as an organization we're
going to stick with them and give them a
chance what teams do you look at now
like who's peaking your interest right
now
where is such a quarterback driven
league then I think you have to look at
the young quarterbacks and who's doing
well I'm here in Tampa so I hear all the
excitement about the blocks and you see
what Jameis Winston is doing and the
confidence they have in him Weston
Mariota was a one two picks a couple of
years back and I think they're about
ready to take off the teams have gotten
better on the
since they get the box have put a ton of
skill position players around Jameis I
look for those through teams to be very
good this year yeah I think and yeah I
agree with you on both of them I think
both teams take that next step I think
Tampa should play up team you know the
one thing that worries being about
Winston is he might be too confident
well that's what they're working on I
know from talking to the coaches and
saying things down here you don't have
to make every single play every play
doesn't have to be a touchdown you don't
have to be the focal point and now the
more people they're getting around him
I think that'll help we went through
that with Peyton when I got there to
Indianapolis our defense wasn't quite
ready yet he was used to having to take
chances having to win games
31:28 so you feel like I've got to do it
on every plate I think Jameis will learn
that and relax and say you know what
it's not going to be the worst thing to
punt it's not going to be the worst
thing to throw this ball away and go to
second down and that's going to help
them when that message gets through to
him any other teams that you're looking
at whether they're going to be better
than what you think or maybe worse than
what you think
well you know I saw the Cowboys at the
Hall of Fame game and that is an
interesting team to me because I think
they have a lot of things in place to I
got to spend some time with dak Prescott
and he was super impressive as a young
quarterback too but this Elliott
situation I think that has everything
kind of in limbo there and what's going
to happen how will they be if it is six
games without their workhorse running
back but I think they have a lot of
things in place to be very good talking
to Tony Dungy football night in America
analyst former bucks in Colts head coach
joining us the Continental Tire coaches
corner today when you look at Colin
Kaepernick as a former coach bringing
him in is it based more on his talent or
why you wouldn't bring him in on his
talent or his political beliefs what
happens before and after a game well I
think there's a little bit of both
anytime you kind of go against the grain
for whatever reason and you have some
red flag then you
you know you have one strike against you
now one strike doesn't knock you out if
you have some other things if you have
some talent you know we've seen that
over and over and over again but what
people are saying now is what is Colin
Kaepernick going to do for me on the
field and they're not ready to say I'm
going to buy into that and put myself in
position to to deal with all the fan
backlash if I don't think he's going to
bring a lot to the table and to me
that's where it is right now if you got
the right system I think Colin
Kaepernick is still a dangerous player
and he could do a lot but you have to
tell your system to what he can do I
really thought Seattle might have been
the best situation because if Russell
Wilson does get hurt you plug Kaepernick
in and you can do the same thing and
keep going with your offense outside of
that I don't know where he fits and
where it's going to happen
we'll have to see you know I thought
Sienna was the perfect place because of
sort of the feeling personality of that
team that part of the country Pete
Carroll is your coach you get a guy who
used to be in the NFC West is the backup
quarterback he's better than Trayvon
Boykin but I was surprised that they
moved on from him yeah and you know
obviously they are worried about the off
the field stuff they've got their number
one defensive lineman who said the same
thing I'm going to you know have a
protest all year and there hasn't been
hardly anything said about that so I did
I thought that was an ideal place for
him to go I also saw the story where you
challenged
Tampa's professional sports teams to
help pay to move a Confederate statue
from front and in front of the local
courthouse there and explain how that
came up and what was the response from
those teams in the tamp area play was a
great response it was an odd situation
they've been talking about this statute
for a month and the County Commission
has gone back and forth they said
they're going to move it everyone
thought it was a done deal that it was
moved and then in yesterday's paper
there was an article that said everyone
thinks is a good eye
they voted 42 to move it but they don't
have the funds and they're not going to
move it unless private funds come
available and they wanted 140,000
dollars in 30 days in the article they
said we don't know if we're going to get
this done and to me it just seems a
little bit ridiculous so my wife and I
decided that we would help out and do
something that we could do we
contributed and then I said you know on
social media we need to get people
behind this and I'm going to start with
the this fourth thing and the response
was unbelievable and not only from the
blocks and the Rays and the lightning
which was gratifying but just from
people giving $5 $10 and so in about six
hours that they raised the money
$140,000 and they had to stop taking
payment so it was gratifying to see the
citizens get behind what everybody
thought was the right thing to do I
won't say everybody but most people what
do you see when you see those statues
well I think as an African American you
see the legacy of slavery and people
fighting to keep slavery in existence
and it may not be offensive to everybody
but it's offensive to a significant part
of our community and we didn't think it
should be on government property in a
government place and that was design I
think everyone agreed with it but then
the question was how to do it and what
to do it and I think a lot of people
just validated everyone's concerned and
said this is something that we should
move not on government property not
honoring a legacy that was offensive to
so many people so you don't have a
problem if it's somewhere else you just
don't think it should be on government
property that was my opinion if where is
it going to be relocated I'm not exactly
sure it's a private family that's
begging it a private Cemetery or
something I'm not totally sure but it's
not a it's not a government property
where it's going to you grew up in
Detroit do what do you remember about
the Detroit riots I just saw the movie
yesterday with my wife and it brought
back some memories I was 11 years old
didn't really understand everything that
was going on
my uncle ended up going into the police
department right after that and rise
into you know Assistant Chief of Police
in Detroit you know just feeling like
there needed to be some overhauls in the
way we did things but I remember you
know dr. King getting killed the whole
thing and it just discontent didn't know
what it was all about didn't understand
it of course I had to talk to my dad
some to learn about segregation and you
know he spent time in Washington DC and
went through segregation so it was all
new to me as a young young kid but there
was frustration and discontent that's
what I remember
eleven-year-old pretty powerful movie
very very great shock you tone I'll see
you in New England or the Patriots going
undefeated this year I don't know if
they'll go undefeated but they got a
pretty solid seed number stuff that but
it's damn and then everybody else
there's nobody on their level this year
no you know that's how it always starts
out that way everybody thinks the
defending champions are on beat and if I
was a betting man I wouldn't bet on the
paper it's not because I don't think
that the best team I just think it's
hard to repeat it's not done that often
so if you have the Patriots versus the
field I would take the field and say
there's somebody that's going to come
out of nowhere and then rise up are we
going to have an awkward situation again
where Bill Belichick walks by and he
greets you and then he greets Rodney and
then he gets to me and then he just
keeps going like remember was at the
Meadowlands when they had the button
back that I think that could happen kind
of awkward yeah I know it's like a coach
Rodney I don't know what you did to kind
of do anything I didn't do anything
Thank You tone I'll see in a few days
looking forward to it all right that's
Tony Dungy Continental Tire coaches
corner Continental Tire the official
tire Major League Soccer soccer fans
expect peak performance on the pitch and
also demand peak performance on the
street that's why Continental was built
a tire for what you do whether you're
heading to the game taking the kids to
practice Continental was engineered a
line of tires that includes the
best-in-class wet braking superb
handling Continental Tire proud
supporter of the Dan Patrick show visit
Continental Tire calm to learn more the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience